hi it's Matthew Martin from details and
I just saw the chief on she show and it
was all about bold tough and masculine
statements there are a lot of pleated
skirts in the collection which is mg
punching staple and for you
fashion-forward guys who want to get
this look pairing the skirt with a
legging or really skinny pant or gene is
the way you can pull this off in the
wintertime one of my favorite looks in
the collection was a red suit and short
combination I loved it because it was
the super bold statement a way you can
incorporate this into your own wardrobe
is by pairing just a red blazer and a
shirt together and put it with like a
pair of jeans even a pair of white jeans
would be amazing and that way you can
pull off the look without going head to
toe read another really strong piece in
the collection was this beautiful pea
coat vest over a long leather jacket the
Pico vest was cropped and the longer
leather jacket came out underneath in I
like the proportion mixing and the pea
coat vest was two coats in one which is
great you could parrot a Pico best part
with the Jackie you already have like
maybe a denim jacket you also have the
leather piece but then you could wear on
its own which is still be a really
strong statement there are a lot of
horizontal stripes in the collection and
I know horizontal stripes can scare a
lot of guys but don't worry these were
really slimming as long as you pair it
with a dark neutral you'll be fine
for more parents videos check out
details calm and follow me on Twitter at
details now